fais moi savoir quand tu commences à
enregistrer ouais
j'ai mes questions sur mon téléphone donc je ne peux
même plus utiliser de papier et de crayon
hein mais parfois c'est
exactement ce que ça va faire mec
c'est vraiment de quoi il s'agit aussi
pas vous savez faire de tout un robot
ou de la
technologie d'accord désolé mec allez-y
[Musique]
ça commence comme un roman et amusant
ils le rendent amusant pour vous et puis assez vite
ça se glisse dans votre vie
c'est ma plus grande préoccupation avec toute la
technologie c'est que c'est  amusez-
vous un peu et puis ce n'est plus
amusant
et vous n'aurez plus le choix
[Musique]
partout où nous allons, nous sommes suivis
et surveillés et à mesure que la technologie évolue,
il peut sembler que la culture de la surveillance est
inévitable
pour la brute que je rencontre  avec trois
personnes qui utilisent la mode et l'art
pour perturber la surveillance
[Musique] les
gens m'appellent skitch et
je suis un fabricant de lunettes qui se soucie aussi
de la vie privée alors
j'ai combiné les deux j'ai toujours été
privé et je n'ai jamais aimé  b  Être devant la
caméra même quand j'étais enfant, les
réflecteurs fonctionnent sur deux concepts, l'
un est
un objectif absorbant l'infrarouge, puis l'
autre concept est
un élément réfléchissant qui est appliqué
au cadre,
la caméra ne sait pas vraiment comment
traiter cette information et  cela peut
exposer votre visage que vous connaissez avec une
lumière vive que vous renvoyez à
sa source d'origine qui est l'appareil photo
ouais le fabricant en fait je n'aime pas
le design de celui-ci donc
je dois en fait le plier un peu
un peu
leur dire un million de fois comment le faire
ça ne se fait toujours pas bien j'ai
concentré toute mon
énergie sur l'apprentissage des
technologies de
reconnaissance faciale et comment je pourrais les
vaincre avec une simple paire de
lunettes
et j'essaie toujours de  avoir une longueur d'
avance sur eux
parce que ça va venir vous savez que la
technologie ne s'arrête pas
c'est sur une lancée donc je suis prêt à aller la
surveillance n'est plus une affaire de criminel
c'est de gagner de l'argent
donc ce n'est pas que vous n'avez rien
cacher plus
c'est voulez-vous être un produit je
pense que cela enlève fondamentalement
un sens à notre humanité
donc tout ce que j'essaie de faire avec vous savez
les lunettes de confidentialité
c'est juste une option pour dire que je ne veux
pas participer
à vous  je sais être suivi et surveillé
partout où je vais
après avoir rencontré skitch je suis venu à
providence rhode island pour rencontrer leo
salvaggio qui au lieu de protéger son
identité a décidé de se sacrifier
alors parlez-moi de ce masque eh bien
ce masque est mon visage
ouais ouais c'est mon visage je  l'a créé comme un
moyen de contrecarrer les systèmes de reconnaissance faciale
lorsque quelqu'un sort en public et
qu'il met ce
masque, les caméras de surveillance
attribueront essentiellement toutes leurs
actions
comme les miennes tandis qu'en même temps, toute personne
qui exécute
mon identité en public comme vous le savez  un lion
si vous voulez crée de la désinformation et la
réinjecte dans le système
et ce n'est qu'une façon dont je
réfléchis à la façon dont nous pouvons
résister à la culture de la surveillance
j'ai créé votre moi surveillan  ce parce que
je suis vraiment préoccupé par ce que la
culture de la surveillance fera
à ce que signifie être humain
lorsque nous sommes surveillés ou observés, nous modifions
notre comportement,
la réalité est que nous sommes toujours
constamment surveillés et observés je
me souviens d'être comme un enfant et
comme si je savais que ma mère me regardait comme si
j'étais juste comme un bien meilleur enfant
qui était comme un bien meilleur enfant
que quand j'étais seul
comme et comme maintenant comme littéralement grand
frère nous regarde tout le temps
qui allons-nous être  quand quand nous sommes
constamment sur nos gardes et mesurés
à un système de valeurs auquel nous ne nous sommes pas
inscrits, rejoignez-moi, vous êtes moi,
j'ai commencé avec un visage d'homme blanc parce
que
c'est mon visage si vous voulez être invisible
à la surveillance,
soyez simplement  un homme blanc en costume la triste
réalité est que nous ne vivons pas en
ce moment dans un pays où l'on
pourrait dire la même chose à
propos d'autres visages
[Musique]
donc il y a ce concept appelé seuss
valence qui
utilise la technologie de surveillance contre
les surveillants ou  contre le
parti au pouvoir, je voulais créer un
projet
qui encourageait les gens à enregistrer une vidéo
lorsqu'ils se rendaient à des
manifestations ou à d'autres actions afin qu'ils
aient un moyen
de se défendre devant le tribunal
s'ils étaient arrêtés ou si quelqu'un
qu'ils enregistraient l'était  arrêté
, j'ai donc trouvé des tongs et il s'agit
de déterminer la bonne taille, je veux
ce que c'est, c'est une archive en ligne de
conception de didacticiels de bricolage pour les caméras corporelles
qui peuvent être fabriquées à partir de matériaux ménagers
ou de choses que vous pouvez obtenir du
dollar
ne pas se soucier de la surveillance,
surtout de nos jours
à l'époque de george floyd et de tous
ces indigènes noirs de couleur
qui ont été assassinés par la police,
c'est aussi ne pas sympathiser avec toute une
communauté
qui est en proie à cela  genre de culture
avec le projet body cam je suis très
inspiré par les matériaux que je trouve pour
éviter d'arriver
donc je vais essayer
il y a une énorme partie de moi qui
veut juste  essayer des
choses stupides pour essayer des choses stupides
comme pourquoi ne pas prendre deux
housses de volant et
dans une bascule et voir ce que vous pourriez en faire
je pense que mon équilibre consiste à
montrer aux gens ce que quelque chose de
fonctionnel pourrait être, puis
le genre plus spectaculaire de  comme
des choses amusantes et folles, c'est comme
ouvrir votre esprit à ce qui pourrait être, je suis en
fait choqué
que cela ait fonctionné euh tu sais que je n'ai pas fait
toutes les autres choses que j'ai faites
à l'autre mais comme je veux dire
tu sais avec  toutes les sangles et les
éléments de sécurité comme
celui-ci pourraient en fait être meilleurs, ce n'est pas
ce qui était censé être,
j'espère que je vais le faire correctement
et que je n'insère pas
une agrafe là-bas, nous
allons bien, donc j'ai qu'il
y a quelque chose à  être dit pour une sorte
d'
humour qui alimente quelque chose de
bien plus sérieux qu'il n'y paraît
être bon tout le monde je suis ici dans la providence
et nous allons participer à
la
manifestation donc je vais mettre ça
entre les mains  -libre sur ma tête et
j'espère que vous pourrez le voir si
vous n'êtes pas en mesure de participer ici d'
accord cool d'accord alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
george floyd je pense que mon
travail finit par poser plus de questions
qu'il n'apporte de
réponses je ne pense pas  que n'importe lequel de mes
projets offre une sorte de panacée,
je pense que ce qu'ils offrent est
une perspective sur ce que vous pourriez
faire
washington pour rencontrer kate bertash
qui a créé une ligne de mode qui inonde
les lecteurs de plaques d'immatriculation de fausses données,
c'était amusant aussi de voir la résurgence
d'une sorte de mode hacker euh vous
savez que nous vivons tous à une époque très
dystopique
et le cyberpunk est gentil  de
réapparaître à la fois comme une sorte d'
influence de la mode dans le monde et c'est plutôt
agréable d'avoir une place dans
cette conversation et de dire que
vous connaissez certaines des idées que nous tirons
de ces images similaires du monde qui a
mal tourné  g
peut en fait être utilisé pour apporter un
peu de plaisir à aimer
le monde de tous les jours en ce moment
il s'agit d'un test de démonstration en direct utilisant une
version de téléphone portable d'un
lecteur de plaque d'immatriculation mobile destiné à être
utilisé peut-être comme un propriétaire d'entreprise ou un
propriétaire similaire  ou quelqu'un et il
utilise en fait les mêmes systèmes que
certains de ces systèmes commerciaux vendus à la
police utilisent réellement,
vous pouvez voir les différentes boîtes qui
s'allument sur toutes les
différentes parties de la chemise où il
pense qu'il détecte
diverses plaques d'immatriculation et cela  est l'un
de mes morceaux préférés, c'est comme si la
conception de la plaque du quatrième amendement se déchaîne vraiment
sur certains de ces systèmes, vous pouvez voir
comme l'écran capturé
le nombre de plaques compte, il
était donc vraiment important pour moi que ces
choses fonctionnent également non seulement
hypothétiquement  mais en direct, je pense
que quelque chose que les gens ne réalisent pas à
propos des lecteurs de plaques d'immatriculation, c'est que vous
savez que vous pourriez en voir un
sur une voiture de police ou à un panneau d'arrêt, mais
malheureusement,
ils ont  sont toujours en train de lire tout le temps et
ils peuvent ingérer des
milliers d'assiettes par minute ils créent
une carte très détaillée
de votre journée
[Musique]
en montrant, espérons-le, qu'ils pourraient être
affectés par quelque chose d'aussi
simple qu'un vêtement que
nous remettons en question  en quelque sorte les places que
ces systèmes ont dans notre société,
ces systèmes ne sont pas si intelligents et
ils ne fonctionnent pas la plupart du temps
et même s'ils le faisaient, nous devrions poser
des questions très importantes à votre sujet,
comme si cela devait être quelque chose que
nous devons accepter dans  le monde
[Musique]
je vivais à los angeles jusqu'à
très récemment
et los angeles est l'une des
capitales de la surveillance du pays,
nous imaginons que les gens ont des
valeurs différentes entre les citadins
et les ruraux, mais
je pense que
tous  nous avons ensemble un
sens intuitif du fait que nous avons le droit
à la vie privée et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui,
je pense, pourrait vraiment vraiment si nous la laissions
nous rassembler tous
[Musique  ] la
future reconnaissance faciale, je pense
que ça va être une bataille et honnêtement, je ne suis pas très optimiste quant au droit des gens à la vie privée, je pense que je pense que ça va continuer à s'éroder,
donc en ce moment, je crois que notre meilleure option,
vous savez, j'essaie de  combattre le système l'
une des choses qui
ressort également de ces projets artistiques
est que oui, je montre des erreurs
dans ces systèmes, mais ils devraient également
nous inviter à poser des questions sur le fait que
ce serait juste pour moi de l'utiliser
même  si cela a parfaitement fonctionné tout le temps
et à mon avis, la réponse est non
quand vous regardez mes ressources
par rapport à celles du gouvernement,
je ne vais pas gagner mais si je peux rendre
leur travail un peu plus difficile
un peu plus  ennuyeux je suis là pour
toi